for eight years Michelle Obama's family
was under America's microscope having
stepped away from the White House
spotlight the former first lady has
opened up about her painful miscarriage
in an exclusive interview with ABC I
felt lost and alone and I feel I felt
like I failed because I didn't know how
common miscarriages were because we
don't talk about it we sit in our own
pain thinking that somehow we're broken
her daughters Sasha and Malia she
reveals were conceived by IVF the
biological clock is real because egg
production is limited and I realized
that is I was 34 and 35 we had to do IVF
I think it's the worst thing that we do
to each other as women not share the
truth about our bodies and how they work
and how they don't work she also speaks
candidly about struggles in her marriage
and seeking help for those young people
out there who think that marriage is
supposed to be easy and marriage
counseling for us was one of those ways
where we learned how to talk out our
differences what I learned about myself
was that my happiness was up to me and I
started working out more I started
asking for help not just from him but
from other people I stopped feeling
guilty but in her new memoir she says
she can't stop her feelings about
president Trump's birther campaign which
questioned her husband's citizenship
Donald Trump she writes with his loud
and reckless innuendos was putting my
family's safety at risk and for this I'd
never forgive him the president fired
back before he left for Paris she got
paid a lot of money to write up up and
they always insist that you come up with
controversial well I'll give you a
little controversy back I'll never
forgive him for what he did to our
United States military there is no love
lost after a brutal election
you don't stoop to their level no our
motto is when they go low we go high but
America chose another man's message and
a very different political universe
would Helia Lynch Sky News Washington